[Music]
welcome to ear biscuits the podcast
where two lifelong friends talk about
life for a long time i'm rhett and i'm
link this week at the round table of dim
lighting
we're talking about gifts
a lot of people thinking about gifts
giving is in the air
your collar just is doing something that
i could well because like i could help
you with all right
you like it on your lady
you like that thank you i kind of feel
like i just want to say i want to get my
neck covered i just feel like
there are limits to the coziness that
you should experience in public
and i feel like you've crossed a line i
love crossing that line well i'm just
saying that i just feel like you've
crossed a cultural line and of you
you're making other people feel
uncomfortable because you're so
comfortable i'm a boundary
so we ask you mythical beasts to tell us
the best gift you've ever received and
who gifted it to you implying that hey
we want a little bit of a story as much
as uh twitter can stomach
uh and we said we might discuss it on an
episode of your biscuits this is the
313th episode and we are discussing that
but we're not discussing that this is
the 313th episode other than that what i
was referring to uh we're also going to
be talking about our best gifts ever and
maybe some of the gifts that we've
received over the years or maybe even
given over the years uh that come up as
we tell some of your gifts
you know tis the season
for giving
and if your wife
has a birthday
of december 18th oh goodness uh man this
this time of year like literally
like right now
because of the time we're recording this
uh i've still had a few weeks and uh no
it seems like by your body posture you
have no plans you know what'll help put
your collar up just for a second just
while you're talking about this just
kind of experience it
well the thing is a little protection
the thing is a little this is what
happens to more
creative i wish that she would change
her birth date i've lobbied i've lobbied
for this and she says it's not
acceptable because i'm like
this time of year you know this time of
year is so busy for us it's like
everything just gets piled at the end of
the year i don't remember to do so many
other things i start seeing areas of my
house where like things are building up
and then i see areas of my inbox that
things are building up and
then i'm like oh i have and don't look
inward
i have to that's how i feel i have to
give something for my wife's birthday
and for christmas and it it matters to
her so no here's the thing it doesn't uh
well
there are two
disparate realities in within my wife
she's a complex woman
number one she really cares about gifts
she really cares about giving and she
really cares about receiving gifts
naturally that is her natural
disposition she comes from a family of
gift givers and extravagant gift givers
and extravagant gift receivers meaning
that when her family receives gifts from
each other there's lots of
emotional release and
and i come from a family where
my mom
like gets everything for herself and
just says you got me this for my
birthday you got me this for christmas
and she she gave me no arguing with that
you know she gave up on my dad and my
brothers a long time ago i mean and we
are we actually want we want to give but
she's just like you're not going to get
it right so i'm just going to get stuff
for myself
and then also in my family you know my
my dad so it's just like you give my dad
a gift it's not like you're not going to
get some you're not going to get the
response that you're looking for you
know what i'm saying you're not going to
get this you're going to oh i feel what
what response are you going to get
because you know what the response my
dad get
yeah i think you can relate to this you
know it gets the shirt and it's just
like where do you expect me to wear this
your dad does super honest my dad does
just enough to feel some social
obligation but not actually make you
feel great about what you got and listen
because i have this and i have a very
similar personality is he kind of
he's doing it for he do he's he's giving
as much as he can muster for
the gifter because for him it's like
gifts don't resonate with him maybe with
you and i
gifts are i don't think with me that
gifts
are resonating more with me as i get
older but the interesting thing about
jessie is that this is the environment
this is the nature and the nurture that
she's bringing to the table but she
married me
and
i think i
i changed her baseline level of
expectations now as i've established
changed you could come up with a
stronger version i am uh i'm a giver in
many ways
uh
and and i actually i like to give
but the thing is is i have a little bit
of like you know she's a she's got
opinions and she's got taste and i don't
necessarily have taste and so when you
so wow a woman with opinions and tastes
what ends up happening is i may not
respond as heartily as she wants me to
to something that is given to me
and then i may not but she but here's
the over 20 years of marriage her
expectations have centered
in a place
i i know centered is the word that i
want to use they have they become more
realistic
and now into a pocket she despair is in
fact you know what she told me
she told me this two nights ago she said
she was like i am so excited
about your christmas gift she was like
you i'm giving you that you're giving
her no she's giving me she said i'm
giving you the it is the best gift
you've you will have ever received crap
and she didn't even know we were doing
this and then she said you know what you
shouldn't even get me anything because
it won't talk that's what she said you
shouldn't even get me anything because
it just will pale in comparison and you
whipped out the contract you're like
letting me get that in writing i've
already worked it out so i'm still good
so i and actually
she will say
two things there's a lot of pressure on
you you feel cool about that you're oh
is that her expectations have centered
lowered sunk whatever you want to say my
gifting ability and my listening ability
has gotten better and the graph of
gifting expectations and gifting ability
has some we've we've met in the middle
i've gotten better her expectations have
lowered and i've actually hit it out of
the park a couple of times
most recently for her birthday last year
which you were a part of when i did the
whole cameo thing with all the friends
and family and the celebrities and then
i gave her something else too and i've
kind of forgotten at this point but
anyway i don't feel that much pressure
from you you wrote her a song dude oh i
wrote her a song yeah yeah yeah i see i
see i'm getting better man but i'm also
getting forgetful i totally forgot i
wrote her a song for her you better hope
she forgot because you don't want her
comparing that to every other gift but
we talked about it at the time it's like
you're gonna have to go back into a
trough to re-center the baseline well i
don't feel a lot of pressure from her i
feel pressure on myself of like i gotta
do this
i gotta do something special for her
birthday she will be with all her family
and my family though because we're you
know flying back to north carolina so
that'll be special and i did take care
with the help of my sister-in-law who
volunteered i didn't ask her
to set up a special private dinner and
some place so we're gonna do that
that'll be nice and then trying to
figure out something to add on top of
that anyway
i'm feeling pretty good about it but i
still have no ideas about christmas call
her down
call her down okay here we go
now we're getting into it
yeah with me and christy
um it's never been that charged around
the holidays you know it is a bit more
of a focus
uh on the kids and on like the struggle
to
get things for the family the the
conflict we have is that like it has
defaulted
to her
to get gifts for not only her family but
my
extended family yeah and that that's not
necessarily fair and has been a source
of uh
tension
um
uh that yeah i mean the solution has
been to slowly just stop giving them
gifts
just like we give you the gift of our
presence and something that not that
just like i'm
i'm gonna give you something to say you
got it but like even if it's just a
picture and giving my a lot of my family
merch is a big win
no we started doing that we're doing
that again this year
well i hope they're not listening
spoiler
but yeah they've come to expect
i'm talking about the nieces and nephews
yeah nieces i like getting my mom like a
hoodie
i mean i think your dad wants a hoodie
oh definitely
anything to continue to get recognized
yeah what he wants to wear yeah because
for for christy it's mother's day and
her birthday are like very very close
together and it seems like they're right
on the heels of valentine's day so
there's like this triple threat of
disappointment right on the wheels right
on the hills is i mean pushing february
14th and then her birthday may 13th yeah
you're like half the year three three
months later yeah you got about a
quarter to prepare for that uh jay's
blue sunshine
said
um this prompt from you guys i can
actually contribute to because the
answer is easy
roxy post a picture a teeny tiny barely
a palm full of chihuahua puppy my mama
and daddy got me for my 19th birthday
okay so you're an adult
um and you get you getting this puppy
uh roxy grew to two and a half pounds
and was the best thing that ever
happened to me we spent 14 years
together
i
makes me want to tear up you know it's
like i mean we know what you start
talking about dogs that are gone and but
like you remember those 14 years
together and that super cute but can you
love a dog that's two and a half pounds
as much as you can love one that's 20
pounds definitely
that's a that is a big of course you can
that is a big life-altering gift
i know um when um
after my papa passed away my nanny was
gifted a poodle
which was not a puppy but like a
a full-grown poodle for christmas that
was named nicholas
for saint nick i don't know if she
changed the name or if that was just a
coincidence
and she didn't i mean it's kind of dicey
when you give somebody a pet and they're
not asking for it i would say
very dicey especially when it's an old
woman you know when was the last time
she had a dog period my papa had dogs
always but they were never house dogs
yard dogs they were yard dogs and um
she
it was not like a joyful moment when she
got that dog but
that dog changed her life yeah
so the people who gave her that gift
which i guess was
it was like teresa
family no that you're on the wrong side
of the family oh it was uh nanny yeah
yeah yeah because you remember little
nicholas the little little white poodle
oh yeah
i was i've been picturing that
after papa died no
i call him both papa but my so on my
dad's side papa neil
yeah he
um you know he when he basically went
for the most part blind
uh one of the he he was given a uh a dog
named bacardi and then that dog kind of
changed his life and that bacardi is
still with nana now do they know or like
the reference yeah
yeah but they didn't change the name
okay so getting a pet companion
can be
a life-altering gift
in a good way i guess in a bad way but
then maybe not maybe you just do
something about it you don't hear about
those i wanted in this problem yeah i
wanted to give some some some cat to the
dog some tip for the tat
uh
carter hastings said my family pulled
some money together and formed the quote
get carter a cat fund
one christmas so i could go out and
choose a little friend and pay for all
of the necessary supplies a lot of yeah
a lot lots of expense goes along with it
and ongoing expense
dave is the best little guy i could ever
ask for here he is the cat in the box
with the cute little pink nose on the
white snout and then the gray
you got to know
i mean i think that if you know
that somebody
i mean easily if you know that somebody
wants an animal yeah it's it's tough to
just give one as as a prescription
it worked out for nanny but it was there
was dicey there for the first month
probably um i mean it's not necessarily
good for the animal
as well if i think i think this carter
thing
does this this is a really good system i
mean you lose the surprise of the moment
but like for me my personality type you
know i want to pick out the dog
or the cat that i'm gonna spend the next
you know 14
to 20 years with oh you know what i'm
just an epiphany i might be having and
it's going to be a huge disappointment
now
okay if it doesn't happen
not for me well
my wife doesn't listen to this podcast
very often i don't think thank god
unless like people on twitter tell her
to so if you're a fan of jessie on
twitter don't tell her about this you
wouldn't share a dog no what if she's
getting me a dog
that's it that would be consistent with
the level of excitement that she
because she knows that i would of all
the things that i do
and the subjects i broached on this
podcast what you're doing right now
i would not do
i'm just being honest when it comes to
gifts and and this will come up in a
story like you know what it's not gonna
happen i hate
like i can't i don't if someone wants to
surprise me i hate knowing that i that i
didn't surprise them like i want to make
them happy
she wants to make you so happy but
here's the thing i'm just thinking about
the logistics of
when our christmas has to take place
before we travel yeah and the fact that
we've already got aboard barbara for a
couple of weeks when we when we go north
carolina so it's like you can't get a
puppy
you can't get a puppy right before
christmas
and then not take care of it immediately
as your as your own family can't be in
its own home right so it wouldn't it
wouldn't surprise me because
i'm on team second dog
it's just i it
the amount of emotional energy and sort
of logistical
fortitude that it takes to make it
happen is to get over that hump so like
that's really the gift is i got over
that hump here's the dog but you so the
more you think about it you don't think
it hit me that it would be a perfect
gift and it would well also would match
her level of excitement
but it's too far in advance too right i
mean does she pick out well not i guess
you could pick out a dog and then what
if the
dog what is in a cabinet somewhere what
if the dog's wearing a barber costume
and barbara's been boarded this whole
time she has been acting strange
she freaking peed in our bed welcome to
my world
lando's like i'm taking my squishmallow
out of the dryer for the second time
because jasper's peeding on my peeing on
my squished mellows okay well barbara
has been well behaved in this area in a
very long time she
rings her little bell when she wants to
go out she like brings it a couple
of something what is it well it's the
fact that it's not barbara or that she
knows there's another dog coming have
you picked have you picked out
have you agreed on the type of dog you
want to get because that
really starts to support this theory
we're
we're not as specific like we don't want
to barbara look like a slightly
different color like we don't want a
peanut butter version of we have not
like the mclaughlins don't get that
specific the only thing i've said is i
don't want a big dog that requires
a lot of activity
i don't think that our family
would support that in the right way like
we don't we're not good enough at dog
walking we need a dog that doesn't
need a whole lot of like energy do you
want me to ask christy no
don't even in fact just forget i brought
this up it's not going to be a dog i'm
going to be getting stuff we will get a
dog eventually but i'll literally forget
about it like i don't think
in my brain
that if you tell me to forget about
something especially something you said
boop i've forgotten it's like the men in
black button like i have one of those
okay so i've forgotten about like what
we do in the shadows so don't be mad at
me you will forget about this
conversation yeah yeah the or the call
it a jedi mind trick
yeah i get uh they don't make people
forget it's not gonna be a dog but it
wouldn't be a bad gift because i hope it
is i think the things that
are necessary when you're thinking about
giving somebody an animal is i you have
to know that they've already expressed a
willingness to invite an animal into
your home and life
um
but just to round things off with the
pet aaron
uh tweeted at us
my aunt and uncle i'm saying aunt no
you're assuming that it must be from
like a certain part of the country or
something it's not the south my aunt and
uncle got me goats
in fifth grade i bred them and managed a
small herd for eight years looking back
the best part was that they lived at my
grandma's house because
i lived in the city limits it let me get
a lot closer with my grandma for going
over there every day that's cool not
only is it i mean i appreciate the
connection with grandma but
if every fifth grader
in america could be given a herd of
goats well you have to make the herd
they just given given a couple let's
forget about all the difficulties of
like where they would be and what they
would be fed but i'm just saying if you
can have every fifth grader
have the responsibility of a herd of
goats for the next eight years yep
that's this is basically like until they
graduate high school
i like this is a social program all our
problems as a society would go away i
feel that do you understand
everything that we argue about
everything that people get so bent out
of shape about would completely go away
and if i ever have the privilege and
honor to run for president my platform
is gonna be goats for every fifth grader
and you know what the environments help
too because they eat trash well they
also will like they can mow lawns and
stuff but they can get out of control so
we might have to do some sort of
cooperative thing where there's like
this class of fifth graders has a herd
of goats i don't know i i need my team
to work on the logistics
but uh just know that that's my platform
goats for as long as my team doesn't
work
okay uh we're gonna talk a little bit
more about
your gifts and our gifts
but speaking of gifts we want you to
know that you
people who wait to the last minute to
get stuff for yourself
mythical stuff for yourself and for
others maybe for the holidays
you're in luck because we have
amazon.com mythical yes you can get the
stuff that we've got over there which is
mostly or entirely different from the
stuff you can get in mythical.com and
it's all prime shipping
so as fast as prime gives to you is as
fast as that mythical merch can get to
you okay
or get to your loved ones i'm gonna do
it again kiko
and i'm not i'm never gonna do that
that's the official
sound of amazon prime
and not really you know what i was
trying to do right it was like uh air
horn yeah the dj air horn yeah
okay
um this one
from
just kate tm
when i turned 15 my grandma got me a
sewing machine
and gave me lessons at her house seven
years later i have a degree in costume
design and i work at a theater running
wardrobe i might have to incorporate
sewing into my goat plan at this point
you can choose between goats or a sewing
machine i feel that too man okay all
right you want to be do you want to run
with me uh co-president co yes
the first ever co-president they changed
the constitution you know what i i kind
of want to be vice president i kind of
want the lack of responsibility
yeah low pressure got it um i love this
lily actually asked for a sewing machine
and got it
and how'd that go she did
she did sew some stuff and she still has
this like handy
thing about her but she does she never
use a sewing machine that much instead
she would do more like um hand
embroidery which is actually pretty
amazing on like book packs
backpacks book book sacks
book taxes where she called pockets book
sacks all that stuff um
but yeah the fact that
her grandma gave her something that
just it either changed or accelerated
maybe even determined her life
trajectory to this point with a degree
in costume design
working at a theater like
just kind of
putting the kindling together in the
form of a gift and then like hit
then the the receiver brings the spark
and it fans into a flame
that
is a pivotal point in their lives that's
that's you can't hope for more from a
gift
right yeah and i and
some people might be like
well i mean if somebody doesn't ask for
something and you're just you're forcing
it on trust me kids ain't gonna do what
kids don't wanna right so
uh
kate
obviously had a predisposition for
enjoying this and it was maybe even in
her blood and maybe that's what her
grandmother recognized i try to give
but my version of this is giving my kids
musical instruments
um or put it you know and putting them
in like piano lessons
uh lincoln is interested in in
production so it's like
what what can we do to to to foster that
and see where it goes
lily's got
it lily's taking more to it like she's
saying when she comes home for christmas
um she's going to take her guitar back
with her to campus
and she also has a keyboard but it's so
big she didn't want to take that until
like she has more of a space when she
can take that and the cat
i think by the time she's going to take
that cat
i don't know if i'm gonna want her to
take the cat and i'm i
i didn't you didn't hear that from me
oh i'm just starting to understand
i mean this is a whole different
discussion
i can tell by your sweater that you
understand cats i'll just leave it
i'll leave it at this
lincoln and i have many conversations
about
understanding how like how to connect
with saka is totally different than the
dogs but be
seeing some success there is rewarding
i'll leave it at that
um give a good give a good life-changing
gift lately well it's interesting
because i don't know is it you know
my lock is is like me in that he's all
over the place right and interested in
so many different things and so
he has
bought himself
with his money that he has earned at his
job
three guitars okay now one was um
according to him the first one was
stolen
but we're pretty sure it was just left
on the corner
by him by him in the neighborhood
somewhere because
what is that app that our wives go on uh
next door and it was like somebody had
found a guitar
on the side of the street you you and
they didn't retrieve it well but
jessie's
was going back months and saw it oh and
so then when she reached out to the guy
the guy didn't respond i think it's
because dude
i put this up here like months ago and
now you're reaching out to me i've
already pawned this thing whatever
it's a cheap guitar pawned it and he's
got like his app his amp you know i was
telling you about the amps these new
amps
that communicate with an app on your
phone of course they do and you can dial
in a sound like i want this guitar to
sound exactly like jimmy page john
mayer's guitar in this particular song
wow so like slow dancing in a burning
room like that riff right yeah and then
like plays plays it and it doesn't sound
like john mayer but it sounds like a 17
year old learning how to play guitar
trying to play john mayer but the guitar
sound the tone is exactly the same and
he's like dad what about merle haggard
uh
so-and-so so-and-so and then he would be
holding you and is it really awesome
like tele sound but you hope to give
them gifts that
that it takes off right but i what i'm
getting at is
you can't you can't control it
with lock and then now shepard's playing
piano violin and now is learning guitar
and so they're kind of doing that but i
think a guitar would be a good gift
for for shepard at this point because
he's like just playing the ones that
there might be three laying around or at
least two and they're electrics though
oh
uh but you know uh one of the better
this is a this is an opportunity for me
to talk about one of my favorite gifts
all right that i got because jesse gave
me
my
uh
nirvana hand pan nirvana is the brand i
say that because they're based in
glendale
local business uh but you know my like
hand drum
oh yes but the musical instrument
but again i requested this
it would have been a great gift but it's
one of those things that like i had
particulars yeah i knew which one i
wanted
because she okay i had played somebody's
a friend's hand pan
a while back this is such a californian
here's the execution right and then so
jesse ended up i played my friend's hand
i had some opinions about it it's not
just california it would uh colorado we
could do this too yeah asheville
asheville there's lots of places in the
world
she got me a russian tongue drum
which is that you've seen that thing in
my house which is about that big
and it's like a metal it looks like a
you know like a spaceship and it just
has these little like you cut outs like
tongues and then you hit it with a
mallet or a little yarn wrap thing okay
and i liked that but it wasn't the i can
get into the rhythm and play with my
hands it wasn't a hand pan right if you
hit that thing with your hand it doesn't
make a lot of noise so i found the
people making them locally i found i
researched all the keys and i wanted to
get the uh the celtic scale
you know mostly because of my scotch
irish background and it seems like a
good place so i had these ideas oh let's
do the d minor
and so then she got it and it was an
amazing gift
i find that most of the gifts that
are my favorite gifts
are the ones that
were my idea and i selected and then
told somebody what uh that's basically
what my mom does i mean how often does
somebody and again my wife apparently
thinks that this is what she's done that
she thinks that she's struck gold this
year we're gonna find out i'll report
back
a totally unexpected unrequested gift
that is as fulfilling as one that you
curated for yourself
that's the ultimate gift
but i don't have a i don't have many
examples of that
i
i don't have many examples of like
favorite gifts that was difficult for me
i i think i'm just i just don't think
that's my love language so it
doesn't resonate but like the biggest
gift that is i mean has to rank up
they're pretty high and you'll have to
help me remember
how to tell this story because i haven't
told this story in so long
that um
i've gotta i gotta pull it back up
um so i was 15 years old
and i was i was just looking forward to
getting my license and getting a car
uh
and
there was a there was a pickup truck on
the used car lot
that
that just a few blocks from my nana and
papa's house in lillington and i was
like that's the truck i want
candy apple red
1987 nissan pickup with uh
chrome wheels pretty redneck
like it wasn't four-wheel drive but it
kind of impersonated a four-wheel drive
did it already have
the size tires on it yeah okay yeah so
it was like
larger tires than it needed and larger
than you would like see like if you saw
this truck it's a little truck you're
not from the south a little too big
you'd be like
okay that's a redneck driving that truck
yeah
and that resonated with me because
that's
who i was
and um my papa took me to see it i
believe one day
and you know this was in the fall and
then that was it and then
how did this happen okay
then i noticed it was gone from the lot
you can see where this is going he
bought me the truck okay you know that's
where this story is going
but
um
how did this
it was gone from the lot
and then i think
i had this theory
that my papa had bought me this truck
but it was it was pretty early before
christmas
and
you know my birthday is in june so
i had a little doubt
but i i did have an inkling
and then um
let's see it's christmas i believe what
happened was
it was christmas morning
oh and i told you that i thought
i had i'm gonna be honest with you and
tell you that i don't remember being
involved on this side of the process uh
i told you that i thought i might be
getting this truck
and then
what had happened was
you were told
that i was gonna be surprised with this
truck
you were given the information what do
they tell me because i either my mom or
my papa or somebody was just so excited
about this gift it's just like i i
assume jessie's as excited as she is
she's probably told christy that's why
i'm not going to ask her what your gift
is because i don't want to have that
information i'm sure and i've already
pushed that i'm sure that if they told
me that i just turned around and told
you um
i can't remember that part if you told
me ahead of time
but the part that i do remember and i'm
actually
well you know i'm a good i'm actually
i'm a tight secret holder you tell me
something if you tell me that you don't
want me to tell anybody as a 15 year old
no i don't know what i was like he was
16. i don't know what i was like at 16.
now like i will take something to my
grave
oh yeah i do not snitch i'm really good
at that too i take pride in that again
it's the button i'm really good at it
because i remember it push the button
and i i don't remember it i totally
remember it and i always want to say it
when i'm around the person who i know is
the person who needs to hear it or would
want to hear it i'm able to
compartmentalize so much that i
legitimately no longer have the
knowledge that's dangerous man that's
like not knowing you have a gun in your
pocket you know what i'm saying that's
well i haven't
i use it it's
dangerous man it it has bit me in the
butt a couple yeah right because oh i
didn't remember that i wasn't supposed
to remember that
it's like yeah it's like keep a secret
is different than forget you know it
so i
i i am questioning my technique
on christmas morning
i'm at home
uh with my mom
opening presents
stuff like that having the whole
christmas thing i get a phone call it's
you eileen
and my mom's in the room i answer the
phone i'm talking to you i'm like hey
man merry christmas what did you get
what i get and and then you you start
then you're like
did you get it did you get the did you
get the big red surprise
whether you whether we talked about it
ahead of time or not
at that point you assumed that i got it
because it was christmas morning but i
don't go to my nana and papa's house
until christmas night so i didn't
understand your your complicated family
traditions so you were like it could
have been anything big surprise let's
assume you were yeah that you were
keeping the secret but also totally
confirming the surprise you're like did
you get the big red and i'm and here i
am like you already knew that you were
going to get this and i didn't want my
mom to overhear
that you were spoiling it for me well
there was no such thing as speakerphone
at the time
my side of the conversation had to be
really veiled i was like
i'm sure this went great
instead of yeah who instead of saying
like i don't know what you're talking
about 10 year old link trying to make i
was trying to try like trying to manage
two people at once because it's like
yeah man i you know what that's probably
going to be tonight you know i'm going
to nana papa's night i'm going to get
some more presents
some may be bigger and redder and
rednecker than others but i haven't
gotten there yet you said something like
that i have no clue what i said but like
that was the dance well hopefully you
didn't say that because your mom would
have known that you knew exactly and
then she
i i she probably wouldn't have
told
papa because this was his thing you know
to like surprise me huge surprise
i get there that night everybody's
opening the presents lots of tradition
lots of family members by the time we
get done with the presents
he's like you may have noticed that you
don't you just you got less presence
here than you used to get
every other year and i always love how
he would go into like
kind of a speech if you gave him the
opportunity to take the floor for
something you may have noticed that you
do not have as many gifts this year as
you've gotten in previous years it was
like a political though all of your uh
half siblings and cousins have gotten
the same amount of gifts that they've
gotten in previous years
let's walk around out back
and i'm like now i have to act surprised
about this huge thing and i just i want
to give him the gift of
me being surprised but i'm not
but i was still elated so i just
channeled that you know i'm a performer
he had it parked out back and it's just
one of those car commercial things
except in 1987
in the 1990s the 1995 1994 commercial
for a 1987 sun pickup truck yeah i got
anything and uh didn't know how to drive
it because it was a stick yeah uh buddy
but he taught me and that was a
connection
a connection that we made and that truck
is still in the family you know what
that's the third pillar of the
mclaughlin plan as president okay okay
pillar number one every fifth grader
gets a herd of goats or a sewing machine
it's up to them
pillar number
three
because those are actually two pillars
yes okay so pillow number i'm tracking
pillar number three is every 16 year old
has to get a manual transmission
car
now i believe in a little late i believe
in electric vehicles and so i don't know
if there's a way to implement this so i
like the race car you like did the
combustion engine we got to get rid of
that sucker
but we got to somehow give kids
cars with a with a manual shifter that
completely makes it more difficult
uh because i think that made you a
better person
and you know you got the paddles the
shifter paddles oh the shifter paddles
aren't anything no yeah you got to learn
how to operate a machine in a way that
is meaningful and you got to take care
of goats put them in the back of the
truck i kept that truck all the way
through uh
college hitting the tree busting the
radiator i mean like near-death
experience so much happened in that
truck i almost died in that truck so
many experiences uh i took that truck
into marriage
and and then um
eventually sold it it well it died and
uh and you got a pretty similar truck to
replace it but it was a toyota i got a
toyota it was also it looked like a
four-wheel drive truck big wheels but
two-wheel drive it was which really was
like one wheel toyota pre-runner
yeah so it was a fake four-wheel drive
truck because uh
you know i was cheap i didn't even get
the extend cap it wasn't a stick though
was it no
i like that little truck those are good
looking i'm trying to get a little truck
again actually they don't make little
trucks anymore
that toyota that style of toyota coma
pre-runner are bigger now than they were
like the early aughts yeah uh that's a
really good truck yeah i like going back
to that my father-in-law had one of
those that i drove that's how i learned
how to draw a stick speaking of that i
just because while you're talking about
this i am going to talk about the best
gift that i ever got oh we'll do it um
because it's the same it's the same gift
that that you got
i don't know how long we had been
married not long we were um
on staff of campus crusade at the time
so
uh
you know we were
not making a lot of money no
and uh and so definitely not in a
position to purchase a car for ourselves
that was not used or really a gift from
someone else is what most of our cars
would have been at the time yeah and uh
christmas morning
this was actually and this was i believe
this was 100
unexpected i i remember it that way
you didn't tell me
you so that i could call you before you
got it and tell you you were going to
get it so we're at my uh in-laws house
for christmas day which is like two
houses down from my own house
and um
well no you know at the time we wouldn't
have been it's just before a lot was
born so we would have been we were
living in chapel hill because we
so but anyway
chris and ashley uh jessie's sister and
her husband you know our key west
buddies uh we're all inside the house
and then you know we're opening like
smaller presents and clothes and stuff
like that and you may have noticed and
then they said there was some sort of
speech
please go outside and go outside and
there are two
2002
or 2003 whatever year it was was the
euro that this was
mitsubishi monteros two bran one was
gray one was burgundy no one was
burgundy and one was gold
and uh they're exactly the same
brand new some like
one of like
uh my father-in-law's like employees had
like driven them up and like put them in
the driveway next to each other
and it was literally like which one do
y'all want like i it wasn't this one's
for you and this one's for you
trouble and fight over the color and i
don't i don't remember it was an easy
decision we took the burgundy one i
don't know why but that was and then i
remember
driving to christmas conference because
we always went to christmas conference
which was the regional conference for
campus crusade the day after christmas
we would drive we would drive on the
26th because we were emceeing between
the conference
and
i remember driving down highway 40 and
pulling up next to you and christy
on the highway in our car that you did
not i don't think you knew that we had
gotten it
and like honking the horn at you and
getting all to look over and seeing our
big-ass suv that we just got for
christmas yeah i mean that was a really
unusual that was a i mean and we drove
the hell out of that car then your tire
blew out
and we just kept going that didn't
happen
but that was that was the most
unexpected and most helpful at the time
gift because it was like we really we
were getting you know we were thinking
about having kids it was
we we needed a car and we couldn't
afford one ourselves so and it hasn't
gotten better than that no
no sibling rivalry except over colors
right you know you got to give them the
exact same thing
got to be equitable
lauren hooks and spines
tweeted maybe not the best but the most
memorable gift my great aunt
got me the board game sorry
six years
in a row
every christmas not as a joke either
legitimately she forgot it's what she
got me each year before the irony was
lost on her
because it's called sorry
okay there's a few things to explore
here um how could you yeah it's like i
think that this i mean first of all you
know as we get older
sometimes the memory begins to fade a
little bit and this is a legitimate
thing that could happen and she could
just have forgotten and apparently
that's what happened but she's but her
thought pattern stayed consistent that's
fascinating that is what i question
what what should i think that what does
lauren want i bet she'd want a board
game sorry's probably the best one first
of all i'm taking issue with two things
here number one you've never said sorry
like a canadian until today i yeah
because i was um kind of impersonating
lauren's great aunt which i never say
aunt either i don't know you've been
saying sorry sorry sorry if you're if
you're
yeah i'm not being me right now okay uh
but the second thing is is i think that
this aunt
gives sorry
to lots of people man she got a buck
deal i'm sorry she's got sorry
somehow she came into a lot of sarees
and
has maybe her system is off and she
doesn't know who's gotten what but
lauren is not the only person who's
receiving sorry
from this great aunt
i mean there's no way that she just yeah
i mean that is the other other part of
the garage she thinks about lauren and
she thinks she'll love this game
it is a great game i like the feeling of
that popper in the middle yeah any sort
of physical feedback that you can get
pop it's very satisfying yeah
um it is a good it isn't you don't lose
the die
because they're contained in that
module this is a good time to ch i
wanted to check in with you on something
you've been waiting for this
waiting for the right time to bring what
up when uh when i was in kansas city
recently uh loch and shepard and i took
a little drive into the city they'd
never you know never been to kansas city
uh we went to
this i think it's called the river
market area
sort of outdoor market shout out to the
people at the brazilian restaurant i
can't remember your name
but you're a mythical beast
and you gave me a really incredible
sandwich and then gave me some cheesy
brazilian bread balls or whatever they
are okay wow
not gonna forget that
but there's a store there
that was a board game store
big board game store
now it's tough business i
but it's also like
also like pokemon cards and stuff too so
okay you know
um irons in the fire that's that's a
good business technique there was a lot
of square footage
for this kind of store but maybe it's
just because i'm so used to la like if
you're selling board games in la they're
giving gonna give you like 10 by 12.
that's it that's gonna be like a board
game closet right but in kansas city i
guess you basically get
what it amounts to like two radio shacks
i i don't know if your radio shack scale
is for your local radio shack if it it
probably doesn't exist anymore but
anyway it doesn't i love the idea of
board games and so does shepherd
and so we're like looking at all these
board games and i'm just thinking man we
should get one of these board games
we're not going to get one because we
have to fly back et cetera but
that brought me back to you kind of
started getting into board games during
the pandemic and then there was this
whole thing about you getting the
national parks game yeah you know the
pandemic the kids are back in school
lily's off at college is the board game
has it died has a dream died i
funnily enough i was thinking this
morning that like
a holiday activity of ours should be
breaking up parks
and it would be a nostalgic event the
neil family had never incorporated board
games into our everyday neil activities
but i thought it was a survivor but i
think yes it can be a nostalgia only so
much time so yeah i think i think it
might can become a holiday thing but
probably only parks i think i could get
is that what you wanted to ask me about
yeah i wanted to know do you still
recommend it yes
and the question i have was a follow-up
is i think i could get just shepherd
into it jessie is a jesse is a wild card
it depends on if like it just she's got
a lot going on lock forget about it he
might step in for a little bit
but could are there games or just two
people can play and it's fun well first
of all there is a single player version
of parks within the game single player
so he can just play behind i don't know
that's not what i'm asking i'm asking
they're good board games in fact i think
you can play with two people yes i think
so i also might just do a little google
search just do best two players stop
bothering me with things that you can
google through
two-player i don't remember board games
if you have any insight hashtag your
biscuits just i wonder what that means
what you can do with six versions of
sorry
at once like is that like a mega sorry
well i wonder if every single one of the
little bubbles makes the same exact tone
bryant alvarado said um my college
roommate gave me a case of kraft spirals
macaroni and cheese for christmas one
year a case solid love it
he gave me a barbecue sauce sampler for
my birthday the next year
nice one of the best friends i've ever
had
yeah you thought you didn't know where
that was going so that's that's pretty
cool brian you got a friend who knows
you
um
but it kind of makes me
want to discuss our approach to gifting
to each other
we've got this like the main thing we go
back to is
that
one christmas
when rocky five came out
we each went to
um in my in my memory
we went to uh roses
and we were browsing the music session
section and we each
decided that we wanted
rocky five so we just both bought that
soundtrack for each other can you name
one song on that album uh from the
streets
coming to man a fighter
doing the best that he can to survive
who's who's yes the survival of the
fittest strive for what is mine the lord
be my witness
i have no clue what artist saying that
because
it was not a recognizable artist but i i
knew that song it was a rap song and it
was on our soundtrack that you got me
for christmas so i memorized it boy i
wish you would just take that part of
your brain and apply it as others i'm
telling you
man i mean it's got some useless
knowledge in there man
um i ca there's no way you don't have
any useless knowledge i could not
remember any
thing about that i don't know what the
cover looked like it wasn't a good
soundtrack of course it was rocky five
what was the best rocky movie i've ever
seen
and the only well you've seen creed no
ever since michael b jordan's bodyguards
gave me the hard shoulder at that party
i i just can't go back to the b jordan
creed came out before that before you
were body checked by his bodyguard creed
was already out
maybe even creed 2 is getting ready
um i like black panther a lot but we uh
we don't typically give gifts to each
other these well okay we
there's the two versions of us that
right or there's a blur there's blurred
lines between the two
there's the the version that you see and
the holidays that we celebrate we
celebrate each other's birthdays
in front of you
on the shows that we make right and then
when the birthday rolls around because
we shoot things ahead of time it's kind
of like oh happy birthday man i've
already like
acted like i gave you a gift on the on
the internet
right
that came out today yeah
um and i don't think that
it's just
again first i don't think it's either
one of our love language to uh receive
gifts well that's what and this is what
jesse asked me all the time because
uh she's like is your
like is it we got to get something for
your dad we got to get something for
your mom
and i'm like oh and she's like i want it
to be like more thoughtful and i'm like
yeah that's that's great
um
and then a lot of times we just settle
on
amazon
gift card or something like that which
is right for a lot of people it's just
like this but that's
actually what
my parents
prefer in many ways
and
they honestly
they don't like my family doesn't care
as much about it like i know that my dad
is not going to be like oh man you
didn't think about me but we always give
them stuff i'm just saying but i think
for but we don't give each other stuff
out of just an obligation and
expectation and we we've never discussed
it actually it's just that
usually
it doesn't happen there's been some
times when
i mean like i remember for your birthday
i got you that hawkman poster one time
and then i got you a
a wooden holder holster that would like
charge your your apple watch and your
phone
and
i was in kind of a mindset of like it
wouldn't charge it oh i it was a piece
of crap no it was just a piece of wood
that you sit your phone in and it like
if you ran the cable through it yeah
yeah it was a holster it was a wooden
hole it was only wood he likes
he has an apple watch i'm going to give
him this but it was a piece of crap i
was experimenting a couple of times with
am i going to become a gift giver
because and i think it was do i want to
be a gift receiver and do i want rhett
to give me gifts and then i discovered
by giving you gifts the thing i
discovered was
it didn't resonate with either one of us
i think that the biggest thing and it's
not about our love languages the reason
why we don't give each other gifts
is
we know
how difficult it is for each of us to
get up the gumption to give gifts in
general
and
i think we believe that we're on the
same page that the amount of work that
we would have to put in
is more than the amount of enjoyment we
would get from receiving so it's like we
kind of have this unspoken thing that's
like we both don't want to we don't have
it takes a lot of time and energy
especially this time of year like what
you were talking about to like
give gifts
you're not
neither one of us really have a felt
need for that so it's like let's just
spare each other the trouble well it's
interesting because
i don't honest i honestly don't like if
somebody gives me a good thoughtful gift
i think it's really cool
but i don't expect it i don't expect it
from you i've gotten i i can't recall
because again my memory doesn't work in
this way but
i've if i've seen some things i've been
someplace and i've seen something that's
like around my birthday or whatever i
there's a couple of like examples that
are kind of
you know
analogous to what you did with the
hawkman thing that i've that and i've
gotten you i can't remember what they
are yeah i will clarify
i think i found the hawkman poster
because i was looking for stuff to
decorate our office at the time
and i was like you know what
i see i
rhett would like this and it it fulfills
a desire that i have to have our office
decorated so it's kind of like me
controlling how you decorate your part
of the office so like i'll take that
it's like it was kind of like i had an i
had another interest in giving you a
poster but i think one of the things i'm
discovering though is that when i find
something
i'm gonna use the example of what
uh what i found for stevie for her
birthday yeah when i find something and
i'm like oh man this is this is perfect
and right they're gonna love it i get a
lot out of that and i think it taps into
the same thing that i like when i like
cooking for somebody you know it's just
like they're gonna they're gonna have
this sandwich and it's gonna be this
great experience and we're all together
so
if whether when you're talking about the
liquid sweat stevie is stevie is
absolutely obsessed with liquid death
the drink which is just water it looks
like you're drinking like a tall boy you
know malt liquor
so don't drive with it but it's just
water and it is really good water and
she just loves it and she's always
drinking one she's very hydrated
and
i just saw it if you weren't looking for
a gift no i'm just scrolling instagram
and all of a sudden i see this liquid
long-sleeve shirt and it's just like
well i don't know i got an abnormal
heart rate detected
are you are you okay i'm sweating
maybe it's because i have my collar up
too let me check my let's see where i'm
at right now i'm i mean why are you
making this about you 74. i'm just
wondering is there something that we
should in the room is in the room that
we should be worried about uh i'm at 97.
oh good lord i don't know
so i'm under a little stress i see this
long sleeve shirt and then i start
scrolling through the wheel or whatever
yeah you know right carousel
and it's like there's a hat there's a
hoodie there's matching sweatpants and
i'm like this has got stevie written all
over it and the timing was right and
then birthday was coming up in like a
week or two i i um
i saw an ad and she and and by the way
she absolutely loved it and felt really
like thought of and appreciated now i'm
not saying i told her i found it yeah
and we don't do that for stevie every
single year we always get her something
for her birthday it usually doesn't
matter but it's like it usually doesn't
resonate it usually is like here's a
gift certificate to something or
whatever because it's tough to find the
things that connect with the person yeah
um but i saw an ad
for something that
i was like this has got christy written
all over it and i was like you know what
i'm gonna buy it it's not something i
i've only recently started buying stuff
from ads and by the way we're gonna do
an episode our 2021 purchases that's
something we're starting to do every
year oh yeah so that's coming up that's
gonna be fun yeah i was like you know
what i'm just go i really like this
she'll really like this and i'll order
it and i'll give it to her for christmas
and now i'm thinking
i'm just going to go ahead and give it
to her now i think it would be more of a
surprise but then i got to start over
for christmas so maybe i'll keep it it's
already wrapped i'm kind of itching to
just give it to her
i don't know what i'll get her for
christmas then but it's a thing that
like she could already enjoy now
i mean i'm not gonna say what it is even
though i don't think she's when you find
that stuff man you gotta go for it
college roommates who give gifts i think
that's sweet um
here's an here's another friend gift
thing that i thought was uh
creative
this is aaron
clemenson thanks for tweeting at us my
roommate my senior year of college
filmed a little bit of almost every day
of our senior year he put it together
like a vlog that needed
that ended up being over an hour and a
half long
having the ability to go back now and
enjoy some of those moments again is
truly special very cool gift idea
um and it's a gift that he was able to
give to himself too
ain't no shame and like a a gift for you
as a gift for me i agree with this like
that hawkman poster um i don't know if
it's called it's called like what the
one second
one second a day or one second app or
whatever yeah all right all right one of
our good friends has done that i think
we are talking about it every year by
the way yeah this is probably the third
year we've talked about it uh but still
never done it but this
that's an hour and a half that's that's
ambitious what but also you get a little
bit of the
you get a little bit more context you
know than just just the one second thing
is great because it's just like okay
it's 365 seconds and and we're done with
it yeah but i do think that these
man i mean this is kind of this kind of
ties in with what we've been talking
about with
getting some footage of your your
relatives over the holidays telling
stories just
it's so easy to commemorate things and
if you don't know where we were talking
about that that was uh
we do car
oh yeah we do carpool vlogs
um on every month on the mythical
society so like a just a 20-minute
conversation i i think it's kind of like
an ear biscuit in a car but you don't i
think it's like an ear biscuit in a car
but i think that that's the wrong way to
brand it which is a separate
conversation now anyway that's what we
were talking about i will say recording
your elder relatives stories
but you know posterity but you know that
uh
you know
i'm sure google is doing the same thing
in other services but apple is basically
doing a you know they're basically
creating these memories right like oh on
this day november 18th 2016. like what
happened google photos does it too i was
actually looking at it this morning oh
look i'm just going to pl
where is it oh there's lincoln and lily
oh this is in hawaii
there we are there's me a waterfall
yep this is this is a so
there's i mean this is our thanksgiving
trip we got into the helicopters
tell me what you've been thinking about
hawaii so far
don't touch it
so that's lando not answering your
question
oh this is cool i mean this is like
because i don't want to take the time to
do this
and they
what in the world is that a steering
wheel of something it was my leg it was
my bare leg in a car
pressure i think it was my number one
job this is us going uh going for a hike
i get the idea well i guess what i'm
getting at is that what this friend
took time to do
the big brow big brother is now doing
what it does automatically like we don't
need to curate our lives because the
computers are doing it yeah and there's
probably like give me my summary of the
year and you probably don't even have to
ask for it it's going to happen it's not
happening right now but i'm still i'm
not saying this this is not a thoughtful
gift i'm just saying that put it on vhs
for your grandparents
okay
i just kind of relived our things our
hawaii 2016 thanksgiving yeah we went
together as families like
how often do i think about that not very
often every day i i do and and i so now
but now here it is it's a memory on my
phone
and i you know i could send that to
everybody in your family everybody in my
family and they would be like thanks for
taking the time to do that yeah i put a
little something together all i did was
literally open an app and hit a button
yeah there's a button it said share you
could send it to the group right now
mistina magik
uh a personalized song by the lead
singer of my favorite band from my
husband for christmas it makes me so
happy each time i listen to it i don't
know what your favorite band is wow
and is there it so they're either a
local maybe a local thing either this is
a this is cameo on musical steroids or
this is a low this is either cameo this
is a very accessible band or this is a
big band with there's a connection
between but you know that the husband
has either way it makes her happy every
time she listens to it
um the cameo version of that the thing
that we're we're pushing for the cameo
montage stuff
i i think is akin to this yeah and
it's losing it's
it's kind of losing its luster a little
bit now as everyone begins to understand
that this doesn't take a whole lot of
work well
it takes money and but it's still a very
meaningful
at the point of sale yeah not the point
of sale but the point of experience oh
yeah yeah
speaking of thoughtful experience tyler
reese
final kicking
tweeted i had the goal of visiting all
50 states before i turned 30 which was
interrupted by kovid on my birthday i
woke up to the house decorated by my
wife with things from my three missing
states wow and the rest of the day was
spent doing activities and eating food
from those states
so thoughtful very thoughtful very so
experiential i love the fact that tyler
had this idea first of all to
get to all 50 states before 30. i i
assume that being in
trapped inside your home and just eating
food from i wonder what three states it
was that he hadn't been to alaska is
probably one of them like if p if you
have to just state i bet it's not for
hawaii no i bet it's um you think it's
like a vermont yeah rhode island i
haven't been i don't want to throw the
dakotas under the bus but i'm thinking
dakota it's easy to miss a dakota it's
easy to miss both dakota
e i'm sorry dakotas it's easy to miss
you
um which one has mount rush less
that one's that one's tough to work up
the gumption to go to on on a closing
note i thought that this one
was uh very sweet
from rachel hamburg
when i was three i got a mini recliner
that matched okay stop there first of
all a mini recliner is a thing of course
it is and this is a great this is a
great gift for anyone who's three well
not only are many recliners a thing but
have you i don't i'm surprised that you
guys haven't done this at your house yet
but
um
lots of people people and it seems a lot
of people with datsuns
are making little living rooms if they
have multiple datsuns in their home
they're like making little living rooms
with miniature
like
couches and tables furniture and artwork
around that's all lower level and it's
like in a room in their house you have
to give a room to a dog but i mean you
got one kid in college you can take
lily's room and make it a dog room uh
i don't know okay start over i
interrupted when i was three i got a
mini recliner that matched my grandpa's
ah we would watch tv and eat our nightly
ice cream next to each other in our
recliners ha my grandpa was my best pal
and my only father figure growing up
miss him every day oh
that's so cute
um and poignant my grandfather had a set
in his recliner
um it wasn't necessarily as inviting as
it seems that your grandfather was
because he just sat in his recliner
chewing on a cigar
drinking
something i it was i think he just drank
wine my grandma just drank whiskey she
she would smoke cigarettes and drink
whiskey and he would
smoke a cigar and
drink something else but i think it was
wine and he had a little poodle
that would sit right next to him honey
bun honey bun get like right up on him
like oh yeah
so
i mean there is a i could there is a
thought that if i had a little recliner
and go back and have my little candy
cigar and my
uh you know my little apple juice
and your little fake poodle your little
little honey bun because there was no
ice cream eating in that chair once you
had a cigar and wine yeah
you didn't need anything i don't know
what he what maybe it was whiskey too
but mama nell buddy she would have some
whiskey every single night
i didn't understand that that was
probably a problem until much later in
life i think it's i think i think this
is such a sweet memory and sometimes
it's like you know
gifts that you can go back to
in your brain
because that you know it's like if it's
a three-year-old recliner you're not
actually going back to the recliner it
could be in an attic somewhere
i like that
you could put your datsun in it when you
grow up yeah and put that on instagram
um well thank you for sharing your gifts
with us the stories of your gifts
uh may your gift-giving be
especially um thoughtful
i got a wreck
give it to us my gift to you uh the gift
that you can give to yourself a musical
pick me up
uh enjoy that silk sonic album anderson
pack bruno mars super group silk sonic
you got some bootsy collins
legend kind of narrating a story that
lasts about 31 minutes
you got a little bit of thundercat in
one song
which is cool
um
but yeah just it's just a
a syrupy retro
soul funk
good time
so if you need that pick me up give
yourself that gift this holiday season a
little bit of the silk sonic get in your
recliner grab your ice cream
your your earbuds
and listen to your heart's content
hashtag gear biscuits
tell us what you think
talk at you next week
to watch more ear biscuits click on the
playlist on the right to watch the
previous episode of your biscuits click
on the playlist to the left and don't
forget to click on the circular icon to
subscribe if you prefer to listen to
this podcast it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms thanks for
being your mythical best
[Music]